of us did he's a faculty at McMaster
University in Canada and he will start
talking he'll talk about contraction of
markup kernels and differential privacy
and this late afternoon sessions you're
going to see a lot of names that either
listed in the end of his talk Daniel's
abusion and so on appearing so it's
going to be exciting go ahead shop okay
great uh thank you so much to have you
um and thank you for being here uh and a
big big thank you for the organizer for
Lalita of Flavia and Oliver for uh
putting together this kind of timely and
great Workshop
um okay so I want to talk about
contraction of Marcus uh and
applications to differential privacy
um so uh so the talk is
um okay so the talk is based on my
collaboration with Flavia and Mario and
I have to say that this is going to be a
two-part talk uh the first part will be
given by Mario right after after this
talk
um okay so um so let's just um talk
about the outline so at the beginning I
would talk about very very briefly uh
talked about the definition of
differential privacy I think you know
after Ilias a keynote I don't have to
spend time on on the definition
um but
um but after after a very quick
definition of differential privacy uh we
would Define High keystick Divergence
which is a certain instance of a of
Divergence and then after that I would
talk about the contraction coefficient
of Markov cannons and then we will see
you know uh what's the connection with
the with the DP and after that
um as an application of this kind of
contraction coefficient in in DP uh I
will talk about uh uh privacy guarantee
of hidden estate projected noisy SGD
um
first I will I will discuss you know the
previous working on the state of the art
results uh which uh basically assumes
that you know loss functions are convex
and smooth and then after that we will
talk about you know the you know more
General case you know our result uh just
to give you a very quick preview of uh
of the result I will show that uh the
Privacy guarantee of hidden State
projected noisy STD converges as the
number of iteration goes to Infinity so
um we can run a hidden estate project in
Aussie SUV as long as we want with a
non-trivial privacy guarantee
and then um
the last part I will talk about you know
kind of the same setting but without
projection so we are going to talk about
the human estate projection free noisy
STD and and Mario will talk about this
in uh in more details okay so let's
um let's um dive in
um
so suppose you know we have a data set X
containing information a bunch of
individuals uh We've compute some
functions on this data set uh but
because of you know the privacy issues
we cannot really just release you know
that that function X
um publicly what we can do we can just
you know uh pass it through some uh
privacy preserving mechanism okay and
what this mechanism does is basically
just generate a distribution okay so the
output is K of X which is a distribution
okay so now we can look at you know
enabling data set X Prime so basically X
Prime and X defining only one entry so
the last entry here uh we compute the
same function on this data set but but
it's going to be different because of
you know uh the data is a lot different
so let's call it X Prime and then again
we pass it through the same privacy
mechanism and the output will be another
distribution chaotic Explorer so this is
a variant of Alias uh uh picture in in
the slides so again as you mentioned
differential privacy uh kind of dictates
some sort of this transcription this to
distribution for any neighboring data
set x and x Prime but what is the
machine measure of distance here so the
original definition of Epsilon Delta DP
was based on hockeyistic Divergence uh
we say that this mechanism is Epsilon
Delta DP if the hockeyistic Divergence
between K of X and K of X Prime is a
smaller than built up for any pair of
neighboring data set x and x Prime and
what is the arciastic Divergence for any
pair of probability measures mu unknown
on some some space of w the hockeyistic
Divergence between mu I know is
basically just uh for any measure that's
uh to look at you know this this
subtraction so mu of a minus E to the
Epsilon Nu of a and then you maximize it
over all measurable set a so this is
this is the definition of the acoustic
Divergence so it's exactly the same uh
destination as as Ilias but but yeah I'm
just using uh the titleistic Divergence
in the definition of the absolutely and
again as Ilyas as Ilya mentioned
um we can Define highkeyastric
Divergence in terms of the Granite
algorithms okay we can say that you know
K is Alpha Epsilon RBP or very
differentially private if there is any
Divergence between K of X and K of X
Prime is a smaller than Epsilon again
for any pair of neighboring data set x
and x Prime
okay so um again as India mentioned
um a very important property of Epsilon
Delta differential uh privacy and also
the very differential privacy is the at
Host processing property and um
post-processing actually says that by
um post-processing the output of a
mechanism we are not going to lose any
privacy and more precisely uh if I have
a Markov kernel PSI then the composition
of K and PSI will always improve the
Privacy guarantee okay so more
mathematically I can say that if I look
at the composition of K and PSI
then
um the compose mechanism will be Epsilon
Delta Prime DP for some Delta Prime
which is a strictly a smaller than Delta
okay and now the question is how can we
quantify this this privacy amplification
okay so the question is what is the
smallest Delta Prime such that uh the
composition is Epsilon Delta Prime VP
okay so if I can quantify this Delta
Prime then basically I can quantify the
Privacy amplification
um so again mathematically I can
formulate this this problem as as
follows okay so I'm looking at this uh
Markov kernel PSI then I consider this
to input distribution new and new okay
so a mu and new are the output
distribution of my mechanism
corresponding to neighboring data set x
and x Prime so mu and Nu are very close
to each other according to the high
calculations okay so now I have these
two input distribution for my mark of
Scandal PSI and this input distribution
induced output Distribution on this uh
on this curve okay so for new the output
distribution will be sine mu and for new
the output distribution will be PSI Nu
okay so
um think of this uh as the output
distribution of my Channel Side
okay so now uh the question is what is
the largest output characteristic
Divergence among all new and new such
that the hakistic Divergence between new
and new and new and new are smaller than
that okay so again mu Anu or the output
of Epsilon Delta DP so we should have
this these two constraints on the onion
okay so now the question is you know how
can we how can we compute this uh this
maximization subject to this constraint
on the input distributions
so one way to answer this question is by
introducing
um contraction coefficient okay so
um
so uh we are looking at this channel
this Markov channel to input
distribution and two output distribution
and uh contraction coefficient is
basically just you know look at the
ratio of the output characteristic
Divergence over the input icic
Divergence and then we maximize it over
all choice of uh input distribution Neon
okay so uh we all uh know these uh
information Theory you know because of
data process Inequality For example we
know that this is always a smaller than
uh or equal to one
um if there exists on Markov Canal for
which the contraction coefficient is the
strongest smaller than one then we have
um non-trivial contraction coefficient
okay so this this definition immediately
gives us uh this type of inequality okay
so the output holistic Divergence is a
smaller than the input highkeyastic
Divergence times the contraction
and this is what information theory is
called strong data processing inequality
or stpi okay so it's strong because if I
didn't have this construction
coefficient this is exactly DPI but now
I'm just putting something here which is
uh potentially strictly smaller than one
so I'm just kind of improving my BPI
so now if I know that the hockey stick
Divergence I know is a smaller than
Delta then I can get you know you know
it's a kind of simple upper Bound for
the outputiosic religions and hence I
can quantify the Privacy amplification
by uh post processing okay so the
composition of K and PSI is Epsilon
Delta Prime DP where now does that Prime
is just Delta times the contract
okay so this is just a very simple
application of the construction
coefficient to quantify Providence
amplification by by post processing but
now the question is can we actually
compute the contraction coefficient for
General a Markov canal side
okay but uh before I talked about you
know the computation of contraction
coefficient let me just talk a little
bit of History
um so this quantity in a contraction
coefficient we can Define it for all
general f divergences okay so we have
the uh ratio of the output F Divergence
over the input of Divergence and uh
people in information field has been
working on this has been thinking about
this for
um almost half a century well more than
half essentially it goes back to
depression uh where um basically you
look at the contraction coefficient on
the total variation distance and he
prove a very very simple
characterization for the contraction
coefficient
um so his result is actually very very
important it has many applications in uh
you know so this is called physics
dynamical system uh of course
information Theory Markov chains it has
many many applications
um with some house and actually look at
you know the same kind of definition
contraction coefficient on the chios
Divergence and ensure that you know
there is a nice connection with the Remy
maximal correlation
um and then all Street and gatch you
know they look at
um the contraction coefficient on the KL
Divergence and they they show some very
nice connection with the uh the chaos
Mutual information on the Markov chain
and then after that there are so many so
many works on kind of different
properties of of contraction coefficient
for General F5 Logistics
um but none of this work is actually
about the hakistic Divergence not
surprisingly because in High classic the
Divergence is relatively young in uh
information Theory
um Community
um in 2020 uh in a collaboration with
Mario and slavio uh we uh kind of proved
a nice characterization for the
contraction coefficient on the hakistan
versions and this is uh this is what it
looks like so for any Mark of Canon PSI
the contraction coefficient under
acoustic Divergence is basically
um
um is
um can be computed by this uh
maximization so we look at uh just two
points in the in the input so um we look
at the High classic Divergence between
PSI of Y and PSI of Y Prime and then we
maximize it over all twists of Y and Y
Prime
okay so and remarkably this is very very
similar to uh the two point
characterization of uh duplications in
1956.
um okay so um let's just have an example
so let's just look at the gaussian
kernel
um so what gaussian kennel does is so we
denoted by Chi Sigma G you know G for
gaussian so what this discussion candle
does it basically just add noise with
better and sigma Square to the input
okay so
um so the input will be just gaussian
would mean why and parent Sigma is good
so uh we can think of this as a gaussian
channel and and we know that information
Theory every time that we talked about
gaussian Channel you know we're always
going to put some constraint on the
input okay so the constraint might be
Peak power constraint or average power
constraint
um so um so using this theorem which
shows that if the gaussian kernel has
Peak power constraint meaning uh if the
input is always bounded
then the contraction coefficient of a
gaussian candle is actually given by
this function Theta Epsilon evaluated at
all over uh Sigma well now this
dysfunction Theta Epsilon is just you
know depends on this Q function
so it has a very very simple form okay
but if R is infinity meaning we don't
have any thick power constraint then we
can show that you know techno Epsilon
actually goes to to one It kind of
increases to one meaning there is no uh
kind of uh uh so contraction coefficient
is actually uh trivial or again if you
have average power constraint instead of
power constraint again we are not going
to have any non-trivial contraction
coefficient again it's going to be equal
to one
um okay so
um there are several books on the con
connection between contraction
coefficient uh and differential privacy
um there are these these four papers uh
they look at you know this this sort of
contraction coefficient for Central
differential privacy not the setting
that we talked about at the beginning of
the talk and also for the local
differential privacy there are um
several works on
um construction coefficient depending on
you know for different kind of F
divergences and they prove some some
could result in in local differential
policy so in the remaining of of my talk
I want to focus on this uh on on this
work
and we want to talk about the Privacy
got empty office uh noisy SGD
um and we post this paper just as few
days ago to Archive okay so let's just
talk about
um privacy granted hidden estate project
noisy STD I would like uh at the
beginning you know I would talk about
the state of the art result and then uh
we will talk about that
uh okay so
um
so one of the most uh basic algorithm
for
um uh for differentially private machine
learning is is noisy SGD um so this is
exactly
um a classical SGD uh but we just add in
a gaussian noise okay so
um in the first iteration we just you
know pick some random point
um uh from Samsung distribution mu on
the parameter space so this this W is is
the parameter space
and then um in the first iteration we
just take the mini batch uh and then we
use it you know to uh you know for the
gradient distance okay so we take the
average of the gradient of the last
multiplied by ETA and then we subtract
it from the previous uh the previous
model parameter
um okay and then we add noise we add IID
gaussian noise repair in Sigma squared
and then at the end you know we just
take the projection onto the uh the
parameters
um okay so let me uh kind of uh write
this this algorithm in a more compact
way so here instead of that that
gradient descent you know I just use
this this function sign so this this PSI
function you know for any batch of size
uh B
um uh this is actually my update
function
okay so
um and after T iteration
um I stop and then I output all the
model parameters all the intermediate
steps I just you know publicly release
them okay so the output is W1 W2 all the
way to WT
um there are so many so many works on uh
privacy analysis of this algorithm and
um all of them are based on some version
of composition results okay so
um we compute the Privacy guarantee of
one iteration and then we apply some
composition to to say something about
the privacy of the overall algorithm of
the T number of iterations the best
result gives us Epsilon data scales as
Rooty and the best RDP result gives us
Epsilon that is scarce as I know linear
in the number of iterations so both of
these result
um are vacuous when the number of
iteration is very very large okay so
Epsilon increases actually goes to
Infinity if T goes to infinity and again
so Epsilon here for RDP goes even faster
uh when the number of iteration goes to
Infinity so
um what these two result implies is that
if I want to have a given level of
privacy on my SCD then I have to find
some other one for the number of
filtration and that means you know the
um the accuracy of the model training is
going to be sub-optimal
okay
um so um after this uh this work you
know after you know all this uh noisy
STD there was a very interesting work by
Feldman at all uh in 2018
um they they proposed actually a hidden
a signal is the SGD okay so what they
proposed was that uh maybe we don't
really have to uh release all the model
from I can just uh train my my mother uh
my my uh machine learning model uh and
iterate okay so I just all this step all
the model parameters you know will be
hidden
um and I only released the elastic trade
so WT is the only output of this of this
algorithm
the the intuition behind this uh this
this model is that okay so
um by hiding all day trade all the
intermediate trade you know probably I'm
gonna improve the Privacy
um of the overall algorithm and
hopefully you know the Privacy does not
go to Infinity if the number of
iteration goes to Infinity but
um but unfortunately this uh you know
their proof technique uh is a steel back
use when the number of iteration goes
same thing
um okay so two years or three years
after after their work uh this kind of
breakthrough I came along so uh uh to
Russia and Cirque in this paper
um they proved that under some
assumption the Privacy guarantee
actually
um uh kind of converges okay so uh they
look at noisy STD with these three
assumptions okay so uh the mini batch
size is equal to M so basically the mini
batch is just full batch
um the loss function is is a strongly
convex and and it is small okay so then
under these assumptions they prove that
running differential privacy parameter
of noisy GD you know the gradient
descent converges as T goes to Infinity
this is an incredible result a very very
powerful result they prove it is great
um basically
um what they showed was that instead of
having
um
some sort of linear dependence on the
number of iterations so look at you know
all these dashed lines
um for the hidden State GD the Privacy
guarantee actually converges
so I can run GD as long as I want
without having a kind of non-trivial
privacy guard okay so here
um the plus are given in terms of you
know different order of any Divergence
and different levels of you know strong
complexity
again this is an incredible result but
those assumptions you know the uh full
batch you know strong complexity and
smoothness are not very practical okay
they do not actually tell us anything
about uh the Practical uh uh private
training
so
um
by ye and shukri and anshuler and Tall
work they basically relaxing of various
uh Assumption of uh the previous work
okay so in the first paper they kind of
relax the full batch assumption so again
the loss function should be strongly
convex and a smooth in the second paper
they relax the full batch assumption and
also the sun convexity okay so the last
uh needs to be only convex and a small
okay and then on on that these two
assumptions they prove that random
differential privacy parameter of noisy
SGD converges as T goes to Infinity
again very very interesting result very
cancer alternative results but the
assumptions are a little bit restrictive
because nothing in deep learning is is
strongly comebacks not even convex and
definitely not as smooth so
um both of these two papers actually
pose open question as to uh kind of
relax this complexity assumption the
first step is says it remains an
important open problem to further relax
the convex against purpose condition for
proving converging granny ATP bound and
the second paper says convexity is too
restrictive when training deep networks
and it is an interesting open question
if the Assumption of complexity can be
relaxed and they went on to say that you
know this appears to require significant
new Machinery as our techniques
breakdown in the non-convex I think
um so
um what we are going to do we want to
come up with some convergent upper Bound
for differential privacy parameter not
RDP but differential privacy parameter
loss function convex or non-convex is
smooth or non-smode uh but for a variant
of noisy STD
and what is what is the variant the
variant is uh what is now known as dpsgd
okay so so dpsgd is is the same as no
evsgd the only difference is that you
know at each situation we have to clip
the gradient
okay and what this clipping does the
clipping just you know gets some
constant clipping constant C and it kind
of clip the gradient if the norm is
going to be smaller than than C okay so
what it does is so if this is this is my
gradient
if the norm of the grid is a smaller
than constant C then I just want to grab
the direction of the gradient and I
break the the norm exactly
okay so this is
um
um you know DPS really was proposing
this paper about the atoll in 2016 and
and I believe it's one of the most
popular algorithm for uh trending
private models
okay so this is this is our result so
the informal version of our result
um
so we showed that dpsgd is Epsilon Delta
DP
um uh for any Epsilon and Delta is upper
bounded by by this ratio okay so
um here p is B over M so think of p as
the sub sampling rate and this constant
Theta is the constant difference Iran
one uh that depends on a privacy
parameter Epsilon learning rate ETA
clipping constant C noise variance Sigma
square and the diameter of the
um the parameter is this
okay so what is important here is that
this upper plan actually increases as a
function of T but then at some point you
know this constant if T is sufficiently
lower This this term here just disappear
and what we end up with is just P times
Theta divided by this type
which is a way is smaller than one
okay and then this actually gives us
that convergent upper bound that that we
wanted
um again so we can run dpsgd as large as
we want as long as we want
and still we have some sort of
non-trivial uh privacy current
um
actually
um this is Theta Epsilon so uh remember
total Epsilon was the contraction
coefficient of gaussian Kernel but here
we evaluate setup function as uh you
know on this uh on this constant so the
diameter of a parameter space plus 2
times ETA times C divided by the
variance
um so hopefully that that makes it clear
that there is a strong connection
between
um a privacy analysis of of dpsgb and
contraction coefficient of Markov canvas
um okay so um
let's just see you know what this this
bound looks like
um so here you know I just pick you know
this this set of parameters are absolute
is equal to three and then for a given
value of Epsilon
um the upper down is actually something
like this so
again after almost 10 number of
iteration Delta converges to something
like 0.002
okay so we convert pretty pretty quickly
um okay so this is uh so here on fixing
Epsilon and I'm showing the convergent
behavior of Delta we can just turn it
around we can fix Delta you know Delta
is now 10 to minus 3 and then we can see
that you know Epsilon converges to
something like 3.2 again after something
like you know 10 number of iterations
okay so again we can run dps3d for
practically infinitely many number of
iteration
and it's still the the Privacy guarantee
is not going to be uh worse than 3.2 for
example so again very counter intuitive
result
okay so
um I'm not going to talk about the proof
I want to just uh go over some technical
ingredients in the proof uh Mario will
take over and talk about you know the
details of the proof
um there are three technical ingredients
uh in the proof the first one is uh we
are going to just Express dpsgd as a
composition of T Markov Cannon
this is not an entirely new
representation of bpscd 12 month at all
they kind of implicitly did that as well
um so in the second part uh we are going
to uh kind of present a new privacy
analysis of ppsgb if
each kernel each of these T kernels
satisfy what we call coupled non-linear
DPI coupled nonlinear data processing
inequality if each Markov kernel satisfy
this condition then we can add a very
very simple
um uh privacy analysis for dphg
and then the last part we prove that
each kernel in dpsgd with gradient
clipping satisfy this condition
satisfied copper non-linear DPI and then
the proof here is based on the
contraction coefficient of gaussian
Markov gamma
okay so let me let me just talk about
you know the first uh ingredients so
here
um suppose you know we have we have this
data set of size n
so in the first iteration of of Markov
Channel sorry in the first iteration of
ppsgd I just you know take the mini
batch B1 and then I use it you know in
the in the update function PSI and then
I add gaussian noise and then at the end
and I do the
um the projection okay so then
composition of these three functions
constitute the first Mark of candle okay
so this is this is k1
okay
um so the second iteration is exactly
the same so um I take you know the
second mini batch B2 uh use it in the in
the update function at gaussian noise
and then do the projection again this is
going to be the second Mark of Channel
and so on okay so we have t Markov
Channel Each of which uh will have three
parts you know the
um kind of the stop sampling uh given by
this uh mini batch a gaussian additive
and then projection
okay so again uh if if I have another
enabling data set X Prime
um so suppose that you know X Prime
um has
um so it differs from my original data
set X only in the first century then we
are going to have exactly the same
Markov KML so the first iteration will
have uh the same uh kind of three
components uh the update function PSI
Prime
um adding gaussian noise and then the
projection the only difference between
uh between K prime one and K1 is
basically this update function PSI Prime
okay so if this different point
happens to be in my first mini batch
then PSI Prime and PSI will be different
okay so we can we can precisely find the
probability that PSI and PSI Prime will
be different okay and that probability
just uh B over n
okay so if uh one is not in my first
mini batch then PSI Prime and PSI will
be the same so that means you know K1
you know this Markov canal and this
Markov Cana will be the same for this
tornado in data set okay so we have um
the same uh uh so the same you know the
next situation will also be represented
by this uh Markov k n and K Prime 2. and
again we have this set of Markov cannons
for
um
uh for this data set X Prime if I
initiate my dpscd with this input
distribution mu
then in this case the output will be uh
the output of my algorithm after T
iteration will be this distribution
and then
um for the other data set the output
distribution will be this
and what I have to do what I have to
prove in order to compute the Privacy
guarantee of this of this algorithm I
have to look at the hakistic Divergence
between the output distribution meaning
this distribution and this distribution
and ensure that this circus Divergence
is smaller than some Delta and then I
will be done
okay and then in order to do that
um uh we prove a small Lemma
so we showed that if for each of these
this uh Markov can a KT and K Prime t uh
if each of them satisfy a couple
non-linear data processing inequality
meaning if there exists some constant
difference around one alpha T and delta
T between 0 and 1 such that the
hockeyistic Divergence between KT mu and
K Prime tenu for two arbitrary
distributions mu and Nu is a smaller
than Alpha T times the hergetic
Divergence between mu I know plus BT you
know sorry A Plus beta t
um if we have this condition that we
call it coupled nonlinear data
processing inequality then we can very
easily compute the hakistic diversion
between the output distribution okay so
the holistic Divergence between the
output distribution will be upper
bounded by this step
okay so now all I have to do is to prove
that uh for dpsgd with gradient clipping
there exists such constant Alpha T and
literally and then I'm just going to
plug it into this formula and then I can
just you know be done with the proof
so how to do this uh stay tuned uh Mario
we will talk about you know this uh you
know the third ingredient
um but um so as the last Style I want to
just talk about you know the takeaway
message
um here we showed that for hidden estate
noisy SGD with gradient clipping
um no private data leaks after a small
burning period so something like an
after 10 20 number of situation
um the the Privacy guarantee actually
converges as T goes to Infinity so again
we can run vpsgb as long as we want
without having uh uh kind of trivial
privacy guarantee and the proof was
based on two very information theoretic
uh concept the first one was you know
this kind of coupled non-linear DPI
condition and the second one was the
contraction coefficient of calcium
Cannon so
um
so information tool is actually very
very essential it's actually crucial for
proving um such a counter-intuitive
results
um so uh we have an open problem so the
open problem here is that do we need
projection for this result can we kind
of get rid of projection and still have
you know the same at the same result
um so hopefully you know Maria we will
also talk about you know some sort of
evidence you know for uh for this open
problem
I think I will stop here and um take the
question
for a couple of questions while Mario
sets up so
this is Ilya so uh uh I think the result
is wonderful because it captures our
intuition that uh the longer we run the
PHD the more private or at least we
don't lose privacy as it goes along
uh the my question is whether
um uh you believe that the delta that
you have
uh
it's catastrophic like there's like it
hides like some dragons
or it's an artifact of the pro technique
um so um
Okay so
Delta hide some Dragon
um what do you mean by that
Delta
like all better off like the uh the
private like the Privacy gets violated
approximate DP so uh we have that
nuclear option that nuclear event that
you mentioned we have it there
absolutely
um
but um Earth effect of the probe
technique or if it's actually captures
some underlying
uh on the line phenomenon
I think this is a I would say this is a
very underlying phenomena phenomenon
because you know all these previous work
you know this these three work that I
mentioned they keep working on the
running differential privacy okay and
then there is no bad nuclear option you
know for the very differential privacy
but as far as I know there is no way
that we can prove the same result or
when a differential privacy if there is
no complexity
so I think this kind of uh uh kind of
nuclear uh
catastrophic you know uh privacy
violation is kind of the underlying
phenomenon for for dpsgb we cannot prove
it for for RBP
interesting thank you
yeah
so maybe we can take the other questions
offline or maybe you can ask it to Mario
at the end of his talk so um our next
speaker is uh Mario Diaz from UNAM and
he will be continuing talking about
contraction of Markov kernel